hello and welcome to this video yep Here
I am again and I lost a couple of points
so the last game because I had to plead
play some idiotic cheetah again and I
didn't play this time I just reside on
one and complained again and I'm
sickened by it I have to say I already
sick about it why do those people not
learn to play some chess on their own
yeah well anyway I complained I'm again
about this guy the problem is is one of
those people who is not cheating in
every game he just cheats in some games
and that makes it a bit difficult to ya
to pin him down ok so I have to come
down a little bit that really annoys
between the wind yeah playing those
idiots and essentially just getting
rating points taken away from you
bye-bye those people weather so I just
resigned as the simply hit didn't have
any head in the north to play this idiot
okay I just got a message from the ICC
regarding that cheating issue I have to
read to respond quickly they do
something in fact that's good but it
doesn't bring my points back so let's
see what we get here we have a brayer
Roy Lopez sorry for that commentary to
be somewhat term and in somewhat
influenced by that by that came earlier
anyway what is he going to do like f4 he
wants to go F for it seems hmm ok I
would like to have some clarity there
under on the a file in earlier game I
went with this kind of idea for Knight
b6 I'm slightly worried about 94 in this
position but i think i can go age 5 I
just hope that not getting killed down
on the kingside don't have that many
pieces around them
I don't see something forcing f4 is
scary so scary move but maybe I can
maybe I'm quick enough here to clarify
on the queenside and then bring the
night bag and f4 is a disturbing move
somehow okay sup 495 that's probably not
sure how dangerous that is if I get this
night back to f6 I should be okay now
that i have opened up the a file i'm
always ready to trade with rougane check
it tries to sacrifice on age five now
with Queen d2 or something I have night
f6 that is why I went back to f6 at 27
minutes so that i have 9 f 6 available
okay so he goes for F for it was the
second idea of course being ready to
occupy that square is out for 94 I guess
so i'm going to put this on 27 and cover
p5 the only thing not so great is that
and i had to play h5 at some moment it's
not so great I'm not a big deal but
would have been better without okay I'm
left did I have 93 I can go 93 here yeah
I think I do
that's surprising you just move the
Queen okay I could take their own be
true but that looks somehow risky i
don't see what exactly he's doing but ok
the six is attacked oops so now I see
why you would have done okay so let's go
before 93 Bishop takes Bishop g4 bishop
moves that looks good
I want to take be two and then have the
Seaport as an asset it should be good
okay so and it's a check the before pond
and be ready to enter oh I can take with
the bishop hmm
I it's also not so bad here and threaten
you okay one counter-attack okay but now
if I Chico and I don't believe it so
true k 1 check King edge to check on g1
I don't exactly see how I'm winning
there
and Cena when I mean a Kangol can do
this that was my original idea but I
felt there should have been something
bad okay now I have something better
check and that was actually covered Luke
a one check that would have been pretty
bad check and check now I get Queen
takes d5 with the shack Queen trade
white resigns okay so managed to win
that game even though I was a very
distracted enough to say okay there was
a good outing for the brayer I think in
general I had a decent position right
here yeah 95 and now yeah I went for
this maneuver which is I think debatable
because it removes that night from
defense of the King side and that can
prove to be problematic the engine
doesn't see much there in terms of oh no
it's see something night age 69 f 6 and
this this is equal according to the
computer this is this is a very
suspicious equal Wow and it's not easy
to defend actually let's say I play
something like here what does white Jim
the engine wants to take here and this
is already losing all right because I
cannot take care this is coming
it's dangerous yeah there was some
danger in this this way of playing down
to leave it okay you went back yeah now
i think the the worst is probably over
here should be ok check yeah and after
that i'm fine i could have gone to the
three already that would have been
better and taking him this is in fact
very strong just getting this ha ok i
didn't see that one kid and this is not
bad just not by far not as forceful here
there and now 93 yeah i'm in good shape
but should be a winner he however it
gets to be problematic oh this is
stronger ok because I just win that
probably hmm yeah I think here yeah I
should be better simply because as a
tech it's not going going anywhere out
here since it was a blunder of course ok
8 is strong and thick steaks I have to
do this and no one is pretty clear yeah
I think it was a relatively clean game
he had to try one of those night h6 one
of those dicey moves i guess to try to
harass my king while my pieces are all
on the queenside ok well thanks for
watching